judge Judith Sheindlin known to most as
Judge Judy made a name for herself with
her no-nonsense attitude tough talk and
long belittling lecture she gives to
people who appear before her but there
are some other details about this legal
lady in her show that she doesn't talk
about all that much since she's too
modest to reveal them herself we've
compiled them here together for your
viewing pleasure ambulance chasers the
defendants and plaintiffs who appear
before Judge Judy are neither assigned
to her nor do they seek her out all of
that is handled by the Honorable judges
producers according to a letter obtained
by radar online the producers headhunt
through small claims courts for cases
that would be fun for the rest of the
country to watch on television in the
letter producer Julie Turner entices a
defendant into bringing his or her case
to Judge Judy with the promise of
appearing on television because let's
face it there's no better place to have
a personal matter settled producers pay
the fines even though the show claims
all the decisions are legally binding
they really aren't that's because the
fines Judy doles out aren't paid by the
cases losers as would happen in real
life court cases they're actually paid
by producers in the same letter inviting
me unknown defendant to appear on the
show
Turner promises that even if this
anonymous person loses the case he or
she won't be responsible for any fees or
penalties any money comes from the
producers which is a sweet deal for most
people who appear on the show as they
tend to have little money because only
real court cases work this way and
that's not the only money to switch
hands on behalf of the good judge
everyone gets paid while it may not be
as profitable as hitting the Powerball
appearing on Judge Judy is a financial
win-win situation for both the
plaintiffs and the defendants if
anything it's probably the closest thing
to an all-expenses-paid vacation that
some of them will ever see Turner's
letter goes on to say that in addition
to paying all the cases outcome the show
also pays appearance fees to all
litigants who appear in the program
along with travel expenses for them and
any witnesses they wish to bring along
of course those witnesses have to have
something to do with the case but still
a free trip to Los Angeles won't ice
anyone to say anything which often leads
to judge Judy's next little known fact
fake cases obviously learning that parts
if not all of a reality-show are staged
isn't much of a surprise these days but
the makers of Judge Judy can deny
responsibility for some of the fakery
because some of the people who are
appear on the show simply fab
entire cases for them back in 2010 Vice
reported that Jonathan coward and his
friends Brian and Kate can continent in
scene story involving two broken
televisions in a dead cat in order to
get on the show
coward got the idea from another friend
who appeared on the show in the 90s with
an actual case producers took the bait
and flew coward and his three friends
out after the taping the trio celebrated
by renting a convertible and drinking
champagne and a hot tub the rest of day
how did it feel to take advantage of
Judge Judy when asked coward said it
felt awesome felt so good and no he
shouldn't feel bad because she's not a
judge though Judith Sheindlin was
appointed to judge by Mayor Ed Koch in
1982 she does not preside as a real
judge on television the set has all the
accessories and details of a courtroom
but what Judge Judy does at most is
arbitration as reported by consumerist
to Judge Judy and other television
courts operate under a contract of
adhesion meaning they are not bound by
real rules of procedure evidence or even
behavior so on her show Judge Judy isn't
a judge making a legal decision she's
more of a mediator trying to solve other
people's problems so at most she's just
a glorified middle school vice-principal
she might have taken down a school when
Tony Rob's mother sent him to
Cornerstone Christian School in Clear
Lake California she didn't think her son
would get locked in a storage closet for
hours a day but that's what happened
they later appeared before Judge Judy
hoping she could get them their tuition
money back they never could have
predicted what followed the defendants
testimony revealed that the majority of
the staff not only lacked the necessary
skills to deal with special-needs
students like Tony but the even lacked
bachelor's degrees the principal only
held an associate's degree in case
you're not informed about the
requirements of a school administrator
they go far beyond attending a two-year
school even worse the superintendent
only had a high school diploma following
a justifiable tirade tremblin awarded
Tony and his mother the total of the
tuition money sometime later the school
was apparently closed down completely
she's inspired others to do good Marilyn
Mosby who prosecuted the 2015 case for
the wrongful death of Freddie gray cut
her teeth on Judge Judy back in 2000 the
then Tuskegee University student
appeared before Judge Judy suing her
neighbor for throwing a baby shower in
her apartment which destroyed the
residence that must've been one wild
shower
according to the Daily News Mosby
handled herself like a pro bringing
photographic evidence of the destruction
with her she ultimately won her case and
from there went on to study at Boston
College Law School the rest is history
talk about stepping up in life thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to see more videos like the one
you just saw and leave us a comment to
tell us what surprised you most about
Judge Judy